FELIPE HOFFA: Hello, everyone.
I'm Felipe Hoffa from the
Google Cloud Platform team.
Today we're going to review
the latest BigQuery news.
Now we have streaming.
And I'm here today with Aleem
Mawani, the founder of Streak.
Hello, Aleem.
How are you doing?
ALEEM MAWANI: Thanks
for having me.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, I'm
very happy to have you.
You've been using
BigQuery for a long time.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
ALEEM MAWANI: About a
year and a half now.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
I know you met our
PM at a conference,
and you asked him for
us to have streaming.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
That was the first feature
request I had from BigQuery--
is once I saw how
powerful it was,
I wanted to be able to throw
single rows of data at it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So you really wanted the
streaming, and now you have it.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
But before we go to see
how you're using it,
what is Streak?
ALEEM MAWANI: Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: Please tell us.
ALEEM MAWANI: So
Streak is-- it lets
you do business process
software right inside of Gmail.
And so things like
sales processes,
hiring, fundraising, deal flow.
Even stuff like bug
tracking, we let
you do that right
inside of Gmail.
And we do that by having
a Chrome extension that
injects our UI right
inside of Gmail.
Yeah, and that's Streak.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's cool.
And I also know that once
you started using BigQuery,
you did something
similar to Big Query?
ALEEM MAWANI: Oh, yes.
We're fans of taking existing
software and making it better.
Like we're doing with Streak,
building on top of Gmail.
And so for BigQuery we
wrote another extension
that makes BigQuery better.
And we called it the
BigQuery Developer Tools.
And we put that on
the Chrome Web Store,
and it basically adds a
few bells and whistles
to the BigQuery UI.
FELIPE HOFFA: And it's
available for free?
ALEEM MAWANI: Yes,
yes, this is free.
It's just for everyone to use.
We open sourced it as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh,
that's wonderful.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you
will be showing us how--
ALEEM MAWANI:
Yeah, I'll show you
a few examples of what it
can do and how we built it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Awesome.
What do you use BigQuery for?
ALEEM MAWANI: The reason we
wanted streaming so much is
because we use BigQuery
two main things, logging
and event tracking.
So application logging.
Basically, all of
our server logs
from App Engine are
pushed to BigQuery.
So we use App Engine as our
server platform for Streak.
And debugging errors,
seeing the performance
of our application--
it's much better
to view that log
data in BigQuery
than it is in the App
Engine log console.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, yes.
Can you show me how you do it?
ALEEM MAWANI: Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
do a demo, please.
ALEEM MAWANI: Sure.
So the first query
I want to show you
guys is just a basic query
that shows the number of errors
that we have on our server,
broken down by the endpoint.
And so the great part
about using BigQuery
to do log analysis
is that you can
write a full on query,
and then group it,
sort it, order by
whatever you want,
as opposed to just doing regexes
in the App Engine log console.
So to make this work, we
take our App Engine logs.
And every minute
or two minutes, we
parse the last two
minutes worth of logs.
We split it up into
different columns,
so we extract different
amounts of information--
whether there was an error
at the host, the endpoint,
the latency.
Just all of the
relevant information,
split it up into columns, and
then put it into BigQuery.
And so this first query
that I'm showing you,
we're basically taking all
the logs that have errors,
grouping them by the
endpoint, and then sorting
by how many errors there are.
So if I run this
query-- and these errors
are sort of streamed
right to BigQuery.
So you'll see these are
a bunch of difference
endpoints on our server.
And then the number
of errors that we've
received on those endpoints
since this table started
logging.
Now the good part is
I can restrict this.
I can add another
WHERE clause that
says in the last hour
or the last 24 hours.
And we can also use decorators
as part of the streaming
to make it even cheaper.
So this is kind of stuff that
we do, just that a high level,
to see-- monitoring
general application health.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's awesome.
So now you know what
errors are happening today,
in the last hour,
whenever you want.
What do you do next
if you have an error?
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
So if we have an error,
then-- so for example,
if we've noticed an error
that we've never seen before,
or an endpoint that's
failing higher than normal,
we'll run another query that
looks something like this one.
Basically, this just says show
me all the details of the logs.
Show me the full set of columns.
Because in this case, we
want to see the actual log
entries themselves and
not do any grouping.
So in this case,
I'll run this query.
It's just going to
take a second to load.
The good part here
is that we can
see a full application
stack trace inside
of BigQuery because we
export the full log.
We extract those
columns, but we also
export the full stack trace.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can you see
the stack trace there?
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
So for example,
this first row here.
We have the path.
And the first line of the
stack trace is right here.
Now BigQuery doesn't
like multi-line text.
So as part of the extension
I mentioned earlier,
we added this feature where you
could click on the row number,
and it would let you see
multi-line text right inside
of BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: On the web UI?
ALEEM MAWANI: Yes,
in the web UI.
Yes.
So you can see here, this
is the full stack trace
of the entire request.
And then there's an error here.
In this case, it happens to be
a concurrent modification error.
So we can debug using BigQuery
as opposed to some other tool.
FELIPE HOFFA: But
you were telling me
you are getting
errors all the time.
ALEEM MAWANI: Oh yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: How do you know
what is normal, what is--
ALEEM MAWANI: I see.
So one thing we do is we power
our dashboards-- our monitoring
dashboards, and also
dashboards in our office--
that show the error rates
of our server over time.
So that's another query, the
number of errors at that time.
And what this does is just
shows a time series of errors.
And so you see this
query here breaks down
the number of shares
by hour in the day.
And not on this specific
path, but just in general.
And so if we see a spike, then
we know to sort of take action.
So we have a dashboard
that has that ability.
But we also, as part of
the BigQuery extension,
again, that we wrote,
we can graph this kind
of stuff right
inside of BigQuery.
So if you saw that
but I basically we
had a button here called
the Timeseries Graph.
And it takes whatever data
is in this result table
and it makes a time
series out of it.
So right here, we can see-- last
night, we had a ton of errors,
and then they've
sort of settled down.
And again this morning,
we saw a few more.
And so we monitor
them on the dashboard,
but also we can
see the graph here.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh,
that's so cool.
Other than errors,
performance is important.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So we want to make sure our
application is fast for users.
And so one way to do that
is just by hand, playing
with the application.
But another way is
obviously measurement.
And so what we do in
all of our endpoints
is we log to our App
Engine logs how long
certain operations took.
So for example, our
application queries
a lot of data from
the data store.
And then it has a
bunch of results,
and it wants us to ship
it down to the client.
In order to do that, it has
to serialize it to JSON.
So that operation,
we measure the time
it takes to do that
operation, and then
we just output it to the logs.
Now once it's outputed to the
logs, it ends up in BigQuery.
And now we query over it and
do all sorts of stuff with it.
You can find mins,
maxes, means, averages,
all that kind of stuff.
So in this case, what we're
doing is the serialization
time, we output it to the logs.
But it's just in a
plain text field.
It's not in a column.
So we're using
regular expressions
to extract it from
one of the columns,
convert it to an integer, and
then run some analysis over it.
So you'll see that the
results in this case, there
are a bunch of different
endpoints here.
First we show the
number of times
that endpoint was requested.
But then the second one
is, how long on average
it took to do that
stabilization.
So right away, we see
1,400 milliseconds.
It's a crazy long amount time.
And then some are really
short, 11 milliseconds.
And then some, on average,
are really, really long.
So what should we focus
on Next what we really
do is look at the number
of hits times the mean
to know the total time spent.
And that's where we
focus our efforts
on performance optimization.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So you don't want to
focus on slow things.
You want to focus on slow
things that happen a lot.
ALEEM MAWANI: Exactly, exactly.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's cool.
I also want to highlight
what you're doing here.
The ability to run a regular
expression over a full table,
and transforming
them to integers,
and then doing all the math?
ALEEM MAWANI: Exactly.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's one of
the reasons I like BigQuery
so much.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
Yeah, there's no
other way we could
have done that using the typical
App Engine logging system.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
Oh, that's cool.
Tell me, how many
customers do you have?
ALEEM MAWANI: So we have
hundreds of thousands
of users in Streak.
FELIPE HOFFA: Users.
ALEEM MAWANI: And
it's a lot users,
and so there's a lot of traffic.
And so the streaming
ingestion actually
helps so much
because we can just
push all this data to
BigQuery as it happens.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
To my needs, 100,000
users is not easy.
ALEEM MAWANI: No.
FELIPE HOFFA: You're
using BigQuery, then,
to know what they're doing?
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
The second use case
that we use BigQuery for
is to understand what our users
are doing in the application.
And so literally every click,
every page they go to-- I mean,
this is typical analytics stuff.
But instead of putting
the event tracking data
into something like Google
Analytics or Mixpanel
or some of these other
services, we actually
put it straight into BigQuery.
And there's a few reasons.
One is we can write arbitrary
queries against our data.
We're not limited to some UI
that doesn't do what we want.
And then also, we can join
those event tracking tables
to other tables that we have
in BigQuery, such as the logs.
But also, we have a mirror
of our App Engine Datastore
in BigQuery as well.
So we can do a join across
that and see four users
to meet this profile,
what's their behavior?
Or for users who live in this
country, how do they perform?
FELIPE HOFFA: Can
you show me that?
ALEEM MAWANI: Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: I love it.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
I'll show you a little
bit of a toy example.
So one thing we do is, because
we're inside of Gmail, we also
record events that
Gmail users do.
So when they go
to a conversation
or when they go
to search or when
they go to a label--
of course, anonymously.
And so this query
I want to show you
is how people use Gmail for
people who live in Boston
versus people who live in Miami.
Do they use Gmail
or any differently?
And so I just did a query here.
This is a very simple query.
All it's doing is looking
at all of our Gmail events.
So whether they open an
email, compose an email
go to search, whatever--
for every hour
of the day for
the last 24 hours.
And then broken out
by Miami and Boston.
And so here it is by hour.
Actually, the graph
but didn't work.
Let me just refresh that.
Sorry, just give me a second.
So I'll run it again.
FELIPE HOFFA: I
see what it counts.
Looking for people
between Boston and Miami
during the same timezone.
ALEEM MAWANI: Exactly.
Same time zone.
And we just want to see
how their usage differs.
And so I have the results here,
broken out by hour of the day.
And I can use the
time series graph
that I showed you guys earlier.
And the red line is Boston
and the blue line is Miami.
And so in this case, we can see
that in Miami, people actually
prefer working in the
mornings much more.
In general, it follows
a pretty similar curve.
But you'll notice that
around 8:00 or 9:00
AM, people in Miami
actually work more than--
or do more email than--
people in Boston.
And that could be
for various reasons.
Maybe the way people commute
in Boston is different.
And so this kind
of stuff helps us
find different usage
patterns of our users.
This is a toy example,
but we use it quite--
FELIPE HOFFA: So if you want
to call them, for example,
you know when is the
best time to call them
based on where they are-- even
if it's the same time zone?
ALEEM MAWANI: Exactly, exactly.
Right now, we're just using
the data to analyze our users.
But eventually, we can give
the same data to our users
to help them be more
effective in what they do.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's perfect.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: I have
another question,
because I know you can do
this and I love how you do it.
BigQuery queries can
get very complicated.
That one is a very long run.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: How do you
manage to write them?
ALEEM MAWANI: Yes.
So I want to show you
another query that's
really complicated.
And basically, what we did
here is build a funnel.
So if I could just
show you our home page.
This is the home
page for Streak.
This is how our users
get started with streak.
And basically, they
come to our site
and they see one
big play button.
And that Play button
basically takes
them to watch various
different videos
based on what their use case is.
So our goal is, a user comes
our site, they watch a video.
And then they like it, and
so they click this big orange
install button.
And so we want to know how
many people are making it
through that funnel, and what
the drop off is at each stage.
FELIPE HOFFA: You have to
visit your website to get the--
ALEEM MAWANI: Exactly.
FELIPE HOFFA: Once you get them
here, what should you show them
what's the--
ALEEM MAWANI: Exactly.
What's the best way for them
to end up installing Streak.
And so we wrote this query that
basically uses those events.
So each one of those clicks
on the website-- whether they
click on this, or the install
button, or a video-- each
one of those clicks is an event
that we create, and we just
stream it right to BigQuery.
So we have all these
events inside of BigQuery.
Now we have to
write a query that
actually does that analysis.
And that query is
actually nontrivial
because it's kind
of like a funnel.
And so we can run the query.
And it's kind of
a pain to write.
I mean, you can see
how long it is here.
It doesn't even
fit on the screen.
And so we wanted
to make it easier
to write funnels, specifically.
So first of all,
here's the results
of the query, which is
if you watch this video,
then here's the
percentage chance
that you actually installed it.
If you watch this video, then
here's the percentage chance.
So it's clear that if
you watch this video--
we want users to watch
this video because they
have a higher chance installing.
But this query a pain to write.
And so we did something
else, which was we
created a sort of mini syntax.
A syntax that let us
write funnels easier.
So I can just walk
you through it.
The first line is funnel.
So you're just telling
us that hey, you're
going to be making
a final query.
You tell us what table you
want to do this funnel over.
And so in our case,
it's the events table.
And then you give us a column
that specifies that session
ID or some unique
identifier in the table,
such that we can track
the same user over time.
You give us a few other columns.
And then the interesting
part is you just
give us a comma- separated list
of the event names you want.
So in this case it was a
user visited the home page
without the extension installed.
The next event was they
pressed the Download button.
The next event was the
download was successful.
And the next event
was they logged in
and a new account was
created, was the file event.
So that's our sign-up funnel.
And so we want to see
how many people make it
through that funnel.
So instead of writing
this crazy nested query,
we added a functionality
to the BigQuery extension
that we wrote, where you
just specify it like this
and then you press the
Expand Templates button.
And now you can see it
auto-generated this giant query
for you to do that funnel.
And so now I can
just run the query,
and I didn't have to write
this big, monstrous thing.
So this is sort
of an alternative
to making your own page
that has your own interface
and stuff like that.
We just used
BigQuery's interface,
but added a little bit
of functionality to it.
FELIPE HOFFA: I love that.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, that's great.
Thank you very much, Aleem.
ALEEM MAWANI: No problem
FELIPE HOFFA: I think we
will leave it here now.
ALEEM MAWANI: Great.
FELIPE HOFFA: If people
want to install the BigQuery
extension--
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
So the BigQuery
extension you can
get in the Chrome Web Store.
Just search for Streak
Developer Tools.
If you want to use
Streak itself--
it's great for bug tracking,
product development--
you can get that in the
Chrome Web Store as well,
and just search for Streak
or go to streak.com.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
my last question
is, how are you getting the
appending logs to BigQuery?
ALEEM MAWANI: So we wrote
it in open source framework
that pushes logs from App Engine
to BigQuery automatically.
And you just have to
install this one library.
It's really easy.
And that's open
source, it's on GitHub.
It's github.com/streakyc/mache.
And I'm sure they'll
put up the URL.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes,
the URL will be here.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Well, thank you
very much, Aleem.
ALEEM MAWANI: No problem.
FELIPE HOFFA: Everybody,
please check out Streak.
It's a great product.
They take the extensions
they're writing--
ALEEM MAWANI: And we're hiring.
FELIPE HOFFA:
They're hiring, yes.
It's a great time to be
a developer, so yeah.
You are based in San Francisco?
ALEEM MAWANI: Based
in San Francisco,
and we love Google
Cloud Platform.
And so if you're into
that, we're always hiring.
FELIPE HOFFA: Awesome.
ALEEM MAWANI: Yep.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank
you very much.
I'm Felipe Hoffa, with Aleem
Mawani, the founder of Streak.
ALEEM MAWANI: Thanks.